ira y frustración entre los inquilinos
que están en riesgo de quedarse sin
hogar la moratoria a los desalojos
permitía a los inquilinos que se vieron
gravemente afectados económicamente por
la pandemia permanecer en sus casas pero
esta protección ha terminado realmente
tengo un plan de ayuda ni tengo un plan
b no tengo familiares ni amigo del el
presidente de eeuu desató una pelea
política del jueves cuando anunció que
permitiría que expirara la prohibición
de desalojo baiden dijo que quería
extenderlo pero sus manos estaban atadas
después de que la corte suprema señala
sé que esta sería la última fecha límite
luego la casa blanca pasó la
responsabilidad al congreso lo que
provocó una intensa operación de rescate
por parte de los demócratas que
finalmente fracasó en protesta a una
legisladora demócrata d'acampo frente al
capitolio
no vamos a dejar que esto suceda en
silencio cuando las vidas de las
personas reales que se supone que
representamos las de los seres reales
las de los seres humanos están realmente
en riesgo por decisión política o la
falta de una entonces aquí tenemos que
estar
fue alguien más de 15 millones de
personas en eeuu están atrasadas con los
pagos de alquiler el riesgo de desalojo
coincide con un aumento en los casos de
kobe 19 en el país impulsados por la
propagación de la variante delta más
contagiosa